[Music]
in tippy-toe news Thibodeau Thibodeau
submitted by pretty and fun that's girls
they're looking up articles for us thank
you
fun wears glasses now the second one
okay
a man with cerebral palsy spent five
years typing a book with only one toe
Wow how did he resist with the other
four I think that's all he has control
over then I one toe with one toe I'm not
sure I just know like he used his big
big toe on his right foot to tap a book
the type of book it's a type of book oh
it's a copy if I meant to tap a book
like he's like oh that's what you meant
by four oh yeah I saw that well how
could he resist like I would want to use
all of them oh yeah he typed up this
book it took him five years like go go
go
you can bend your foot you got to turn
it on first though yeah there you go no
one ever you said wait - that's [ __ ]
hard dude wait oh yes banning chair -
that's really dangerous props because I
can't do it he's that's bad skills so
that's the only appendage he has control
over I'm assuming because they don't
really go into details of like how like
how much control he has over his body he
just they just mentioned that he has
cerebral palsy and that he was born with
it obviously and so he's from Singapore
easily hmm oh no cuz I said so it's not
Mabley either you're born with it or
it's mabeline but since he was born with
it it's not from me oh yeah yeah so
maybe she's brought with it maybe it's
maybe she's born with it we know it's
not married don't try to take credit for
this
maybe those how to take crackers they're
definitely not Maybelline 38 year old
Wesley we that does not sound
Singaporean at all Wesley we there's a
lot of Chinese in Singapore oh oh no no
their national language is English oh
[ __ ] me well apparently have you heard
of Ho Chi an okay Volken that's Chinese
Chinese Chinese okay so I guess that's
pretty much Chinese people is like
another Taiwan you know what happened
Chinese people of Malaysia said you know
what I don't think I want to be a part
of Malaysia anymore so we're gonna make
our own thing and call it Singapore oh
yeah so he's saying that when he was
born he or like growing up with his
parents it was always really difficult
because he would have to endure a lot of
abuse from his parents so like his mom
would hit him and say things like you
good-for-nothing [ __ ] up see Gina
which apparently means dead child in Ho
Chi Yong it is better if you die she
would tell him that and then do but
[ __ ] she's the one that's the reason
why he's like this yeah and then his
father would push him to do a lot of
difficult exercises every single night
and attempt to make him walk normally so
he would do is have forced him to walk
using a walking frame and he would force
something to do ten rounds around the
living room every night but obviously
like it was really hard - a lot of times
he couldn't do it and he would just beat
him he would drag me to the bathroom
dunk his head into a bucket full of
water it's like it's so sad cuz he's
saying like he only had a like few happy
childhood memories and that those were
with his grandmother who took him away
from his parents but then for some
reason they he had to go back to his
parents and he couldn't live with his
grandma sucks Wow inspirational quotes
of a asian parent abuse those are their
ideas of an inspirational quote let's do
it or I beat you up so then he was
saying that his parents they were just
so eager to make him walk normal that
they
had him they had him undergo a procedure
and that procedure ended up making
things worse and found him to a
wheelchair because before that procedure
well he was able to kind of walk he was
able to walk a little bit but just not
like normal so he was like uh what's his
name on Breaking Bad Brendan Walt Walt
whoops
while jr. while jr. yeah they call him
Flynn oh yeah we gasp oh then he was
just saying that after the whole surgery
he had to get he had to just be in a
wheelchair and then he would endure even
more abuse and it's really sad
he actually attempted suicide four times
and he was saying that he claims that
Jesus gave him the strength to push
through and helped him find his calling
which was to become an inspiration to
those who believe that life has nothing
for those who believe that life has
nothing left for them so he wants to be
an inspiration for these people so
that's why he wrote this book took him
five years it's called finding happen
finding happiness against the odds
so here's wesley I need to buy that book
for my friend really way my friend is
paralyzed and he tried to commit suicide
by not breathing but yeah what do you do
hold his breath yeah he held his breath
when he was in the hospital when he
found out he was paralyzed oh yeah
like neck down or always down neck down
motorcycle accident no he was yeah he
was on top of the roof for July 4th and
try to jump into the pool she made it
but when he dove his head hit the bottom
of the pool my god and what was it like
a three foot pool no I think it's from
the force
you know Oh cause it was so high up that
it just boom and people do that all the
time you have done it yeah so since then
he's been paralyzed and I go visit him
once in a while kind of overdue to see
him but yeah he's not least China he's
using all these like equipment to help
move and we have so much he paralyzed
from the waist down to the neck down
like what is it just a neck down but
he's moving it in his arms we're not his
fingers when he eats it's like yeah
go like this and really grip on stars
yeah a big motor fine motor movement
yeah to go [ __ ] slap someone [ __ ] get
out my room yeah more that's why it
takes a lot of energy to do he Wesley
looks like he's he's like he can move or
maybe just a picture
no yeah strong yeah no yes I'll show you
guys because of how thick his limbs are
and stuff is that what your vision
shoulders are pretty big not mean like
in yeah in this photo he looks like he's
just sitting upright and I pictured him
to be like Stephen Hawking mmm cuz like
if he could only use at all I'm just
assuming he can't move anything he can
to uh shoot video he looks like he does
curls show you guys a quick clip there
for the gun so just so you guys know he
did find a wife like he met her online
and he brought over to Singapore and so
he's happily married so he has a happy
life he gets [ __ ]
that's how you felt like he needed a
writer but I don't think you feel II
know you can't control it but maybe you
could feel it
that's dull cerebral palsy I think so
it's not like if someone slaps them in
the army can't feel it
oh yeah cuz it's not me it's not like
you're paralyzed yeah yeah so you get
hella [ __ ] yep I don't know I don't
know [ __ ] about cerebral palsy I'm just
I'm just wondering I'm happy for them
yeah cuz I like I like people like this
because it makes me realize what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] I am sometimes me to i go
you know i don't want to wake up today
because i asleep and then i think Wesley
wakes up every day and he can't you can
only control his toll or you can use it
to type up a book but he only has one
toe to type up a book and then sometimes
I don't want to even write emails but I
got all my phalanges take things for
granted here we go slap yo sis okay
they contracted everyday like showering
and even eating makes a living on the
street selling tissue paper cuz all he
can do to support himself and his wife
[Music]
his condition affects not only his
muscle control but also his ability to
speak and be understood that's all cool
then why are all these guys complaining
that they can't get dates and they do
all this [ __ ] this guy could barely talk
he can't move and he has a [ __ ] wife
what the [ __ ] are you doing
he's also lucky that he sounds like
Richard sugar too though you got that
bad southern boys I think that's a manly
deep voice hell yeah
there's 54 Asian guys yeah we don't have
deep voices so he's good oh listen to
his voice is it really that deep you
made it yes I buy his book I'm gonna buy
his book I want him to live off of the
book and like be a writer I hope it
doesn't suck though well I mean you just
you have to buy it to find out there's
no summary the first book
don't download it illegally now well
here is this is just a flyer of the book
so they have here it's a flyer of the
book launch is gonna be launched at
Google Singapore I think this was doing
it all wrong he should be a rapper so he
has all these struggles right he's
trying to write a book when you got a
deep bass voice you even got a type that
[ __ ] and they just get in the studio
started after I went to deep bass boys
with their struggles then he put all the
rappers out to shame that's true because
he got some real [ __ ] I can't even move
can't move my buddy
like that I don't know if I can listen
to that he says no he kind of sounds
like yeah he kind of sounds like Rick
Ross though if you think about it huh
watch after he watches this video he's
gonna make his own rocking chair huh
yeah yeah
there's always Oh Wesley we that's a
rappers name
Wesley weed oh I think Wesley and rich
[ __ ] should get it to get a collab
going on and start that Southeast Asian
[ __ ] yeah cuz like you know we already
had the West Coast we had the East Coast
we had the Midwest we had the south now
we need Southeast Asia
yeah let's go easy Southeast Asian trap
I like you to trap trap music I wanna
hear that the weazy we'd come into your
hood I hope you guys enjoy this video
for more please subscribe to our Channel
and you can check out the last video
right here
[Music]
[Music]